WAY.
>> Tucker: DOCTOR, IT IS GREAT
TO SEE YOU TODAY.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Tucker: DETROIT, MICHIGAN,
THE MOST VIOLENT PLACES IN THE
UNITED STATES, AND THE PLACE
WILL BE THERE IN MINUTES AND
THAT IS WHY THOUSANDS OF
LAW-ABIDING CITIZENS IN DETROIT
CARRIED THEIR OWN FIREARMS AND
DEFEND THEMSELVES SO WE WENT TO
DETROIT TO MEET SOME OF THE GOOD
GUYS WHO CARRY GUNS.
PART 2 OF THE SERIES ON BEING
LEGALLY ARMED IN DETROIT.
>> DETROIT FROM EMERGENCY 911.
>> LEAPT >> IT WAS A NIGHTMARE
SITUATION WITH A CONCEALED
PISTOL LICENSE.
>> I WAS ARRESTED, HANDCUFFED
AND TAKEN TO THE JUDGE HOUSE --
JAILHOUSE.
HE WAS HOME FROM A CHRISTMAS
PARTY, DRESSED AS SANTA CLAUS
AND STOPPED AT A GAS STATION TO
HELP A FEMALE COWORKER CHANGE
HER ENTIRE.
>> INDIVIDUALLY I APPROACHED HER
AT THAT TIME AND I PHYSICALLY
PUSHED HER AND I WAS
INTOXICATED.
I INTERVENED AND IT WAS A
SITUATION WHERE HE WANTED TO
SHOOT A FIREARM AND WE HAD A
SHOOT OUT.
I WAS CHARGED WITH SEVEN
FELONIES FOR DEFENDING MYSELF AS
WELL AS A FRIEND.
>> HIS CHURCH HELPED HIM COVER
MORE THAN $50,000 IN LEGAL FEES.
AFTER MORE THAN A YEAR IN COURT,
A JURY CLEARED HIM ON ALL
CHARGES.
>> HE IS CALLED THE SANTA
SHOOTER AFTER ARRESTED FOR
OPENING FIRE AT SAINT NICK.
>> NOW HE WANTS TO GO BUY A NEW
NAME, FREE MAN AFTER ACQUITTED
OF ALL CHARGES.
>> LIKE THOUSANDS OF DETROITERS,
HE HAS A LICENSE TO CARRY
CONCEALED WEAPON.
>> THE POLICE CHIEF HAS A RIGHT
TO CARRY.
>> THERE IS RISHA ENDEMIC
RESEARCH THAT CITIZENS FEAR MORE
THAN THE POLICE.
>> THE THING ABOUT IT, WHEN
INTOXICATED, TO DE-ESCALATE THE
SITUATION AND CALL THE POLICE
AND THE POLICE WILL ARRIVE IN
TIME.
>> BY THE TIME THEY ARE COLD IT
IS USUALLY AFTER-THE-FACT.
SO THEY ARE REACTING TO THE
CRIME.
>> THE POLICE DEPARTMENT WITH A
TASK, RESPONSIBLE FOR A CITY AS
LARGE AS PHILADELPHIA, BUT WITH
ONE-THIRD AS MANY OFFICERS.
>> THE POLICE DEPARTMENT AND
STAFF IS BASED ON POPULATION.
THE POLICE ARE NOT EVERYWHERE OF
EVERY MINUTE OF EVERY DAY.
OFTENTIMES WE NEED TO HIRE MORE
POLICE OFFICERS.
IT IS NOT REALISTIC.
>> IT IS A SENTIMENT ECHOED BY
FIREARMS INSTRUCTOR RICK.
>> A HIGH LEVEL OF CRIME HERE.
THEY WILL MAKE EVERY EFFORT TO
GET THE RESIDENCE AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE.
THEY MAY NOT GET THERE FAST
ENOUGH.
>> THIS IS NOT BEING A
VIGILANTE.
I'M NOT ADVOCATING THAT.
BUT I'M ALSO ADVOCATING NOT
BECOMING A VICTIM.
AND THIS IS STAYING ALIVE.
LET US JUST THE REALITY.
THAT IS ANYWHERE.
>> DETROIT'S RATE OF JUSTIFIABLE
HOMICIDES KILLED BY ARMED
CITIZENS IS 20 TIMES HIGHER THAN
THE NATIONAL AVERAGE.
>> BAD GUYS LOVE GUN CONTROL.
ADDITIONAL LEGISLATION, ANTIGUN
LAWS, IT WILL NOT STOP BAD GUYS.
>> BAD GUYS, GOOD GUY SHOULD
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE